if you want to see how deep this stuff
is and this is what you have to
understand because you might be watching
this and I think the average person
watches this stuff and they're like why
is it it doesn't make sense when I've
been to these stores in other targets
and and other stores like this there's
never anyone buying any of this stuff
right there's never anyone in those
sections you never see anyone wearing
any of this stuff so the question is why
is it there and it has much more to do
with how these organizations are set up
the diversity Equity inclusion groups
that are in their ESG and more than
whether they have a desire to make a
profit and that is a problem this is
video of Target CEO Brian Cornell
explaining that it is his mission now I
thought the mission of a Target CEO
would be to sell as much crap as
possible so the Target stock price goes
up so the shareholders are happy you've
put out a product you make some money
you go home but no his mission is to
advance diversity equity and inclusion
some of the companies that I've worked
with whether it's Target today or in the
past working for PepsiCo you know that
Common Thread was recognizing that
diverse and inclusive environments
deliver great results yeah and I've
always tried to ensure that our
leadership team our organization
reflected the consumer we serve and when
you get that equation right it's the
right thing for society it's the right
thing for the team it's also the right
thing for business and shareholders so I
think we all have an oversized role to
play right now to advance diversity and
inclusion
to stand next to our black leaders who
need our support to make sure it's
really clear in our industry and our
companies we're not going to tolerate
racism and to work to make the right
changes both internally and then working
as a collective group to make changes in
our communities and in our country that
are going to have a lasting effect
guys he's not going to tolerate racism
by hiring people based on race he's
going to literally look at skin color
and gender and sexuality and hire people
in exact accordance with their
demographic oh God it's so terrible note
he didn't step down I would imagine that
there's a black guy out there who's
capable of being the Target CEO and yet
you've got this rich white guy Mr
Cornell okay Cornell's got some cash but
Cornell is going to defeat racism by
hiring ex-black lesbians and why trans
this and that the other thing again you
know people goes in I had him on the
show years ago when he was talking about
this that once you let I don't even know
that people were really fully calling it
diversity equity and inclusion yet but
once you let this woke mind virus into
the system whatever system it's in it
will destroy the system because then you
have people like CEO of companies again
who whose only job his job is to grow
Target to sell product to make as many
people want to buy the most amount of
goods possible there right and then
that's the beauty of capitalism because
another big box store could open and
then they could go oh there's Best Buy
is selling TVs cheaper than we are we
better lower our prices then competition
happens we get more development like
that's the beauty of the of the whole
thing but then when you have this woke
mind virus in there and you're caring
more about how many black lesbian uh
greeters you have at the store uh you've
got a problem because you are now not
doing what your main mission is as a CEO
of a company
[Music]